hi can I help you hi um yeah I was
interested in the fake franchise and I
heard I could come here for more
information
oh come on in make yourself at home look
we're always looking for new plans to
join our course so we're here to make
things as easy as possible you can ask
me any question okay so when do I start
Hey set that question is there not
beginning do you want the long version
or the short version the short version
so in the beginning there was fate/stay
night which is a visual novel in three
different routes fates are linked to
plate words and heavens feel which needs
to be played out in that exact order now
the theta route has been adapted once by
Studio Deen in 2006 as an anime series
unlooted played moistens been inducted
twice once my studio Tina's a movie and
once by a final as a full series who are
also adapting heavens feel but only as
Trinity of movies only of which one is
out at the moment I thought you were
going to give me the show version this
is the short version so technically
speaking enemy wise 2016 adaptation is
the beginning and serves as a good
introduction to the world okay so why
can't I just start with that other [ __ ]
oh yeah in terms of main line
adaptations only the ones y-you
furnivall are worth watching but you
can't start with face thing right on
them to play boys because that spoils of
fate zero
what's phase zero oh oh it's just a
frequent up takes place before faced a
knight themselves as a good introduction
to the world of face alright so I'll
just start with phase zero well no
because faint zero spoils face pain
Knights heavens feel we're always so in
other words fate/stay night spoils
fate/zero and fate/zero spoils face they
night yeah that makes no sense that's
why you should just read the visual
novel alright how long's nothing around
a hundred hours that's a pretty big
committed read the visual but I don't
have a hundreds of visual college just
read the [ __ ] visual novel or not I
can never give myself anyway okay well
that's everything right
[Laughter]
there's more do you want long version of
the short version the shoe OCU I try to
do which is a continuation to face state
nights but only existing visual novel
form at the moment with no anime
adaptation now you also have faint
prototype which is a reimagining of the
whole face they night events but only in
a one episode ova form so that I faked
Apocrypha takes place in the completely
awesome universe and this includes one
anime adaptation and one light novel and
of course there's the faint extra verse
which is another alternate universe and
this includes three games fate extra
faint extra Triple C and fate Xterra and
of course they can also has one anime
adaptation in feint extra last encore
okay so I'm guessing the only connection
with all of these is that one chick with
the sword
you mean saber yes oh no they're totally
different characters well you see the
original saber is meant to be King
Arthur who in faith law is actually a
woman now these other sabers aren't
actually King Arthur they're completely
different characters who also happen to
be women and also happen to be in the
saber class okay so you're saying that
this isn't the original saber nope this
that's right and everyone here there are
different characters have looked similar
and these two sabers are also different
from each other pill aluminum you see
one's red saber and the other one is
saber of red get it no it's pretty
simple and they aren't related to the
original state you were at all only
saber of red do you mean the saber
that's red or the one that looks like
saber yes she's actually the original
saber son and saber King Arthur is her
dad wait a minute you literally just
said they were all girls
you said it but how do though it's
basically the same as standard Arthurian
legend except this time King Arthur is
given a dick by Merlin who can then be
forced to point by her wife so she can
make a baby and then out pops Mordred as
your standard homunculus
baby there's no way that's cannon
Chloe's cannon if you want to learn more
about law in the servants then the
mobile game faint go is a good starting
point um
do I dare ask if I should get into fake
Oh depends do you have powers of money
you wish to burn and countless hours to
spiral downwards Granick way in a
never-ending cycle to satisfy your love
for your fate life use that you'll never
ever get back no you don't want again to
Faygo another course that's fate Callie
and prison marília which is a magical
girl spin-off of the original fate/stay
night
I haven't think I need to watch that it
has lesbian lollies kissing I think I'll
need to watch that come on before I
forget there's also the quickie spin-off
by Studio you faceball or basically the
cast of things day night to cook food
and stuff and all of this is all part of
the greater nasty first wish to explain
to stop okay stop this is too much this
is a complete [ __ ] how did this
get so out of control I literally have
no idea